TSpeaker 1: oday, I'm going to be
speaking with Professor Alastair Smith,
who teaches politics at New York University
and is also coauthor of the book The Dictator's
Handbook Why Bad Behavior is Almost Always
Good Politics. Really appreciate your
time. Great to have you on today.
Speaker 5: Very glad to be here.
Speaker 1: So let let's start with this. This
premise that bad behavior is good politics,
because it seems maybe to to the layperson that
sometimes bad behavior is actually bad politics.
But it seems that maybe more internationally and
less so within the country wherein that is taking
place. So is it important to distinguish when
we say bad behavior is good politics, whether
we're talking about international reaction or
within a leader's country, or does it does it not
matter? Does the principle hold true regardless?
Speaker 5: Well, I think we should stop learning
about what's good or bad. We should worry about
what leaders choose to do. And what leaders should
do is what's good for them ought to emphasize
them as the particular individual and not the
country. So the president, the United States does
what is good for the president, the United States,
Kim Jong un does what is good for Kim Jong un.
And that typically means keeping those people
happy that you need to stay in power. Difference
between why we get much better governance in the
United States is because the US president needs
the support of tens of millions of people and Kim
Jong UN needs the support of tens or hundreds of
but certainly no more than thousands of people.
And it's that scale of how do you keep
the appropriate people happy determines
the kinds of policies that leaders have.
Speaker 1: That's interesting. So in the
United States, the good politics are that which
will get you reelected. In the system we have,
which includes 100 plus million people voting,
obviously with the influence of lobbies and
corporations and all of these other things in
North Korea. Similarly, the good politics that
keep you in power are those immediately sort of
around you who could try to depose you. But it
is less about the population of North Korea.
Speaker 5: Right? You should never make the
mistake of thinking leaders are out there to
make life good for the people. And so the U.S.,
I don't think if the US is behaving in a very
particularly normatively good way with respect
to overseas politics, which is I think where
you where you started this conversation is
because the US president is not beholden to
the people in other countries. So the US,
the president's job is to enrich and improve
the welfare of the people that he needs to
stay in power and we shouldn't expect
him to do anything else. So foreign aid,
military intervention is designed for
promoting the interests of the people
the president cares about and not the
interests of the countries where aid is
being delivered or intervention is taking place.
Speaker 1: If we look at a situation like Russia,
which is being sanctioned heavily
because of its incursion into Ukraine,
there was an interesting NPR piece I heard
about a week ago which argued that despite
whatever is being publicly said about the very
limited impact of the sanctions, the sanctions
are actually really disastrous for Russia at all
levels. I guess we don't know definitively whether
that's true or not, But let's let's imagine that
it is the case that the sanctions are having a
disastrous impact. How does that change or impact
this balance of what is good to stay in power when
you introduce an external force like a sanction?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, again, what sanctions
I always think of whenever sanctions are applied,
they've almost always filed before they start. If
the sanction was going to be a big enough
stick that it was going to get compliance,
that the leader in the in the target state
would have already complied with the threat.
So the fact that they're being applied means
that they're almost certainly not going to work
and that why do they get applied? It's because
it's domestically popular for Western Europe and
North America to apply these sanctions.
So it's good for the president to do it,
keeping the constituents happy. It may
actually be very helpful in Russia. Want
one of the crisis? One of the consequences? Price
of oil is higher, so there's more revenue. Also,
the fact that there's now limited options for the
oligarchs to try and enrich themselves in another
way. All the revenue, all the wealth, all the
benefits that are coming politically now comes
centrally through Putin because the sanctions
have limited the access. And so in some sense,
it's given Putin a little more power. This
is our problem with sanctions. You know,
when the US sanctioned Iraq against Saddam.
A sign. One of the consequences was that the
value of smuggling became much more valuable.
Who controlled the smuggling? The cronies of
Saddam Hussein, who became massively wealthy
because the population suffered as a whole.
Speaker 1: If we if we stick specifically with
dictatorships and sort of pseudo dictatorships
with authoritarian strongmen and those types of
countries, what are the most effective strategies
for weakening a dictator's coalition of supporters
like we talked about, that the general population
can take what works, what doesn't work?
Speaker 5: Well, the the real problem is
dictators, once they are well-established in
power, they're very, very hard to bring down.
So you need to look for moments of weakness in
bringing about change. And we should recognize
that we can't just bring down dictators because we
feel like getting rid of them. You know, I think
most people in the United States would like to see
the North Korean regime replaced, but that's just
wishful thinking unless the U.S. is willing to
invade, which I think would be a very, very poor
policy. Just expecting that the people are going
to rise up and bring it bring the regime down
because it's a terrible regime is not going to
happen. Right. So you need to look for moments of
weakness in regimes and in in autocratic regimes
such as North Korea, that the times of actually
much more likely to be health related than any
other reason economic leaders can survive terrible
economic crises. We can think of, you know, the
sanctions in Iraq. Saddam Hussein survived those.
It took US military intervention to remove him.
We could look at the Venezuela the Maduro seems to
have held on to power. The economy has been driven
into the ground, but he made sure that he paid
just the right number of people, just the right
amount. So they stayed loyal. So the military
are well-fed and he survived in power. We can't
just give instructions to the people and say, this
is going to happen. You need to we should accept
that these regimes are going to survive in power.
Speaker 1: When we look at instances
in history where a regime has fallen,
what are some of the most notable examples
that were not health related that come to mind?
Or are there any notable that come to mind?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, for failure to
pay people the right amount of money and harming
the interests of those who keep you in power. So,
you know, the Russians are in World War One. I
mean, he had this crazy tax he used to tax vodka,
but because he didn't want to drink being drunk,
he sort of banned vodka during World War One.
They cut off a huge amount of revenue, cut down
on the amount of money had to pay people. Then
what did he do? He turned around and told
the soldiers that were guarding him at the
Winter Palace. They were going to get sent to the
front line to fight to fight the Germans. Well,
they didn't want to go fight the Germans
at the front line. And what did they do?
They opened the gates and allowed the people
to come in. And so the revolution succeeded.
Generally, leaders are deposed because the
people around them allow the masses to succeed
or they take care of it in a coup themselves.
It's very rare that the people will succeed.
And so that's a case where, quite simply, the
Russians didn't pay the right people, didn't
reward them properly, and they turned on him. The
classic case I like to think of as Julius Caesar.
So Julius Caesar, we think always, you know, if we
follow Shakespeare, we think of him as trying to
be a tyrant. Well, he was already he was already
the dictator. He was already effectively the king.
The problem for him was he actually
tried to enrich the people,
those huge debts from the wars that had been
incurred and meant a lot of regular Roman citizens
were being sold into slavery because they couldn't
settle their debts. And he tried to alleviate this
debt burden. Unfortunately, the people who owned
the debt were the senators around him. So when
he tried to get rid of the debt, he tried to help
the people. And look what it got him. It got him
stabbed by by his fellows in the Senate.
Speaker 1: If we go from the autocratic
circumstances and dictators to democracies,
one of the features or bugs, depending on your
perspective about democracies, capitalist
democracies, Western democracies, is that
the very nature of the economic circumstances
of large swaths of people we can think about
the United States in this case is that they are
overwhelmingly in a position where they can't
afford to coalesce and take the actions that
might be most impactful in the sense of, well,
mass rallies at urban centers and not going
into work for a month and so on and trying to
cripple the financial system. These are things
which we can all imagine having an impact on
the country and at least having the potential to
achieve some change. But because health care is
mostly tied to employment and because 40% of the
population can't meet an unexpected $400 expense,
the system itself creates a population that will
find it more difficult to activate in a way that
is more likely to achieve change. Can you talk
a little bit? Do you agree with that analysis?
Can you talk a little bit about whether that
does become its own impediment to activism?
Speaker 5: Well, I think I see sort of a little
bit disagree there. Most Americans don't want to
bring down the American system of government is
the American system of government is incredibly
representative. And the government, by and
large, generates huge numbers of public goods,
a safe environment, law and order,
transparent government, a national defense,
all these public health, these things are provided
and these are precisely the things people want. So
we protest because we would like the government
to work harder. But we actually have a system of
government we actually like. The very few people
seem to want it. I mean, Trump's attempt to take
over the government, the relatively few it was
thousands of people thought that was a good idea.
The vast majority of the people did not show up
because they like the institutions that we have.
You were discussing the inability to coordinate.
It's the it's the people who really want political
change, who don't have the ability. You and I, we
have the right to free speech. We can say what we
like. We can meet with our friends. We can go
where we like, we can publish, we can talk, we
can speak. People in North Korea don't have those
freedoms. They have a terrible form of government.
Yes, they live in abject poverty. They're not
allowed to go anywhere and not to say anything
economically. They're terribly
off. They would love to change
their system of government, but they don't
have the ability to. In the United States,
we have the ability to protest. We just you
know, the systems the system isn't good,
isn't isn't perfect. But we shouldn't strive to
perfection. The system is good. And therefore
most of the time we don't want to bring it down.
Speaker 1: Well, I guess it's interesting to think
about it with something like, for example, health
care. And when you look at polling about health
care, the polling seems pretty clear that even
across the political spectrum, people generally
believe that the government should provide some
basic level of care, regardless of ability to
pay. Not everybody supports Medicare for all very
clearly. And the more information you give about
Medicare for All support actually goes down
a little bit. But some minimum level of care,
that would be something that you would think is
okay. We have a functioning superstructure. But
this is a pretty big program that we would like
to see function differently. It doesn't happen in
different people point to different things. Well,
the amount of influence that the health insurance
lobby has or the Republican politicians don't
want it, or there's too much money to be made
for the doctors under the system we have or
whatever the case may be. How would the type
of analysis you do look at something that
is a pretty clear desire from the people,
but that doesn't seem to be getting any closer?
Speaker 5: Well, we should remember that the US,
whilst it's a good system, isn't perfect and
winning winning a seat in Congress doesn't require
like half the voters in your district. First of
all, the districts are highly gerrymandered. Yes,
many of them are. And so often you just think
to win the primary, winning the primary. You
can often win with five or 10% of the votes in
the in the primary. So we really now thinking
that to win a seat, to get representation, we're
looking at, let's say, 10% of the population of
the voting population in a district. Well, that's
much smaller than thinking about half that we tend
to think of as democratic. Right. And so if we
want to produce changes that are going to produce
more what I always call public goods, things
that benefit everybody, good public health care,
national defense, things like that, then we want
to always work to increase the number of people
to whom politicians of a home. So, you know, to
win the presidency and clean up the House and
Senate. MALONEY When you think 25 million votes
is enough, if you put them in the right seats,
because it's not it's it's first past the post
and the seats are extremely unevenly distributed.
And we got the Electoral College. So you don't
need you sit there. I think it was 360 million
people all in the US. So, you know, let's say
there's 200 million, so you need 100 million
voters, but you need a quarter of that because not
everybody votes and things are disproportionately
set up. So the white for my perspective, the
way to think about improving public policy is to
make leaders accountable to more people. The more
people they're interested in the the smaller the
impact of specialist lobbies like doctors, health
care lobbyists, health care, insurance companies.
If if you've got it by you know, if you've got
about a thousand votes, you're going to listen to
them a lot. If you've got about a million votes,
you're going to listen to them less. And so so to
me, that is always the the solution to this is not
legislative or anything like that. It's changing
the institutions by which governments operate.
Speaker 1: And I'm trying to think through the
math of like the congressional district. So if
you've got a very lopsided congressional district,
let's just call it that there's 750,000 people per
congressional district, although I think it varies
a little bit. But let's say it's 750. If voter
turnout in the general is 50%, but not everybody
is even eligible. You're talking about a couple of
hundred thousand total votes. But then the primary
might only be a fraction of one party. So you're
down to 80 to 100000. And if only 20% come out,
that's 20,000 votes. And you need 51% of that
to win the primary. You're talking about like
12,000 votes might win you a congressional
primary and that might be all there is to it.
Speaker 5: That's exactly that. That's exactly
the kind of math. That's how I like to think
about political systems. I don't like to think
of them as in some nominal terms of democracy or
autocracy or whatever. I like to think of the
mean exactly that. That's exactly the kind of
calculation I like to think about classifying
political regime. So let's think about how we
can change those things. Like the result,
lose a law. So if you lose a primary, yes,
you can't run in the general elections in.
Speaker 1: Six states, Right? I don't
think that that is everywhere.
Speaker 5: And no, they divert the
rules because the elect, the Constitution
says the electoral rolls are set by the by
the states. But in a lot of places, you
can't run again. It's makes it very hard
for a centrist candidate that might appeal
broadly to actually get through the primary
and then run in the general election. So these
these are the kind of changes that I think are
useful for getting implementing health care.
Speaker 1: The book is The Dictator's Handbook
Why Bad Behavior is Almost Always Good Politics.
And we've been speaking with the book's coauthor,
Professor Alastair Smith from New York University.
So appreciate your time and your insights today.
Speaker 5: Very, very glad
to spend some time with you.